for the first time in 12 years israel
has a new leader benjamin netanyahu's
battle to stay in power
finally ended in defeat over the weekend
after four
extremely close elections in two years
failed to unseat him
naftali bennett is the new prime
minister leading a fragile and
politically diverse coalition government
president biden has already called to
congratulate him charlie dagetta
is in jerusalem outside the israeli
parliament for us charlie good morning
what happens now
tony in a sign of the tensions that are
already here from
day one normally there'd be a small
inauguration
ceremony at the prime minister's office
but benjamin netanyahu
has declined to take part
[Applause]
street celebrations broke out the moment
it was announced that benjamin
netanyahu's 12-year
reign was over at least for now
i'm over and i'm very happy i've been
crying for an hour
it's a celebration it's it's better than
my birthday i'm
i'm 25 years old and i've never been
more happy in my life
deep divisions remain and the challenges
ahead
are many but for those who have been
pushing for benjamin netanyahu's exit
tonight there's cause for celebration
not for everybody netanyahu greeted
supporters who cheered him on after his
loss
underlining the razor thin margin just a
single vote
that came at the end of a tumultuous
session of parliament
netanyahu saddled with corruption cases
he denies and defiant to the end
vowed to wage a daily battle he said in
order to bring
this government down ousted by the man
he mentored
49 year old tech millionaire naphtali
bennett
joe biden the new prime minister
underscored the importance of the
relationship with the us
thanking the biden administration for
its backing during last month's conflict
in gaza
but he doubled down on netanyahu's
criticism
of washington's pledge to renew talks
with iran over its nuclear program
calling it a clear mistake he leads a
shaky coalition that crosses the
political spectrum
from the far left to the hard right
including for the first time an arab
islamist party
a coalition united by a singular goal
that's already been achieved
getting rid of benjamin netanyahu
in that phone call between president
biden and prime minister bennett last
night they discussed the importance of
the alliance between the united states
and israel
the government faces its first real test
tomorrow a right-wing march that's
planned hamas has already called
for a day of rage adriana all right
charlie dagon jerusalem thank you